πανηκερίσαμε όλοι ο μκολόγι είπαμε είδατε τι κατορθώσαμε όταν το ανέλησαν όμως η γερμανή με
τη συστηματικό τεκάντους και ανέλσαν τους ασθενείς που πριν τοσπται χρόνια ήταν σε πρόιμο στάδιον
που έγινε η διάγνωση κι την επιβίωσην αυτόν και τη ανέλησαν το ποσοστών των πρόμο
καρκίνω τώρα με την επιβίωσητους ήταν περί που το ίδιο δι βλέπετα ότι και είμαστε
βέβαιοι ότι πρόληψη είναι το πιο βασικόστιχείων ελάχιστεί ήταν η διαφορά διαιτρίατέαντις εκατόν ήταν ηδιαφορά
που φίλεται στα φάρμακα και λιβά της νέες μεδόδους και λίπάτους την ιατρική μας το
βασικότερο ήταν η πρόληψη και επίσης ανέληαν αυτούς τους ασθενείς τώρα που διαγνώστηκαν σε προχωρημένω
στάδι και τι διεπίστωσε ότι είναι μεγάλης ηλικείας οι ασθενής ιιατί γιατί η πρόληψη επιβάλλεται
επιτρέπετε η επιχωρηκείται μόνο μέχρι μιας συγκεκριμένης ηλικείας αυτό πρέπει να αν ενθεωρηθεί αυτό πρέπει
να δούμε και εμεί τκαστην κύπρον μέχρι πότε γιατί δηλικεία φαίνεται ότι αλλάζει το προό
γεμο βέβαια έχει μεταυληθεί ρβώς επομένως εδώ πρέπει να αναθεωρίζουμε και εδώ πρέπει να επικαεντρωθούμε
γιατί υπάρχει άύξηση κάθε χρόνο και στη χώρα μας σε ότι αφορά της διαγνώσης καρκι
διότι το προσδόκημο ζωής ανέρχεται επομένως ι πιθανότητα